je crois pas à la vaccination
obligatoire pour ce vaccin parce que
d'abord il faut être toujours très
honnêtes et transparents on ne sait pas
tout sur ce vaccin comme on ne sait pas
tout sur le virus
après je crois beaucoup plus on travail
de conviction par la transparence cal
l'obligation conviction transparence des
mots lourds de sens mais qui ne
reflètent pas la réalité d'aujourd'hui
début décembre à l'aube d'une campagne
vaccinale compliqué emmanuel macron
affiche sa confiance envers les français
sur twitter il va même plus loin je les
dis je le répète le vaccin ne sera pas
obligatoire ayant confiance en nos
chercheurs et médecins nous sommes le
pays des lumières et de pasteurs la
raison et la science doivent nous guider
sept mois plus tard le constat est amer
et la confiance envers les françaises
semblent s'être évanouie bien sûr ce
changement de cap radical de l'exécutif
sur la vaccination intervient en pleine
recrudescence du variant delta mais le
rétropédalage est pour le moins
saisissant s'adapter ne veut pas
forcément dire menacé et pourtant
olivier vers ans n'hésite pas à employer
les grands mots à partir du 15 septembre
si vous êtes soignants et que vous
n'êtes pas vacciné vous ne pourrez plus
travailler et vous ne serez plus payés
oui le variant delta change la donne
mais le pass sanitaire élargi interroge
il est même considérée comme liberticide
par l'opposition
une forme de désaveu pour le
gouvernement a dès le départ l'idée d'un
passeport entre guillemets pour accéder
à des lieux publics du quotidien est
balayée par emmanuel macron lui même
dans la presse régionale
même son de cloche au sein du
gouvernement qui multiplie les sorties
dans les médias notamment cédric au le
secrétaire d'état chargé du numérique
qui assure sur europe 1 quelques jours
plus tard que l'exécutif écarte son
utilisation quotidienne car cela ne
correspond ni à la culture française ni
à la temporalité de l'épidémie lors de
son audition à l'assemblée nationale le
11 mai dernier la députée macro nist
yaël brawn peavey défend corps et âme
son amendement empêchant le passage du
ter de concerner les actes du quotidien
donc je crois qu'il est vraiment
important de l'inscrire clairement dans
la loi pour que le chaque citoyen de
notre pays puissent l'opposé à toute
personne privée qui pourrait avoir cette
idée saugrenue de d'imposer de pénétrer
dans son établissement à la possession
d'un tel pas sanitaire et ce n'est pas
tout puisque le secrétaire d'état aux
affaires européennes clément bonne
confirme dès le lendemain sur le plateau
de france 2 qu'il n'y aura pas de passe
sanitaire au quotidien pour les cafés
nous ne voulons pas d'une société à deux
vitesses dit il
des promesses tombé depuis aux
oubliettes à partir du début du mois
d'août le pass sanitaire s'appliquera
dans les cafés les restaurants les
centres commerciaux ainsi que dans les
hôpitaux les maisons de retraite
établissements médicaux sociaux nous
aussi dans les avions trains et cars
pour les longs trajets là encore seuls
les vaccinés et les personnes testées
négatives pourront accéder à ce lieu
qu'il soit d'ailleurs clients usagers ou
salariés l'art de se contredire poussé
au paroxysme des mesures qui portent
atteinte aux libertés individuelles pour
l'opposition c'est désormais au conseil
d'état de trancher la semaine dernière
l'institution a confirmé l'utilisation
du passani terre malgré la demande de
suspension de l'association la
quadrature du net
le juge des référés considère je cite
que se passe ne porte pas une atteinte
grave et illégale au droit au respect de
la vie privée ou au droit à la
protection des données personnelles
mais les dernières annonces des manuels
mâcon change la donne puisqu'elle
concerne désormais les activités du
quotidien